You mentioned that we should not be on our phones when using the right machine.
How about if we have a sticker or device on the phone that changes the unhealthy way
the EMFs affect us?
Will this still interfere with the right frequencies, specifically on the air's tech device on my phone?
Well technically, or technically you could be on your phone when you're doing the right.
So the frequencies from your phone are not going to be powerful enough to change or alter the frequencies
that are coming out of the phone.
So it's not going to harm the treatment frequencies.
You're not going to have a negative effect on the treatment frequencies from the right machine
by using your phone.
It's, you know, is it best to not be, you don't have multiple frequencies coming at you?
Yeah, probably be better, but you know, I'll be the first to be honest and say, I sometimes
am on my phone when I'm running the right, I mean, sometimes at work when I'm running the
right, I'm on my computer.
So, I mean, you just do your best, the best you can.
Don't ever think that anything you're going to do is going to negatively affect the frequencies
coming out of the right because that's coming out in a much stronger power than anything
that's coming out of your phone.
So you're not going to have a negative effect on the right.